Jana lost two friends last week a
teenager killed nine people at a Munich
shopping center before turning his gun
on himself days earlier another teenager
armed with axe and knife attacked
passengers on a train near verts Berg
and in ansbach a man killed himself and
injured others after setting off an
explosive device how is Jana 41 coping
with this spate of attacks
it's more throaty one thing it makes you
sad but also afraid to know the sort of
thinking hunger mr. fortunately it's
hard to believe that people were killed
her that this is where it took place
it's awesome all they wanted to do was
go and sit in a restaurant then someone
came along and shot them it's hard to
get my head around out there buying
14-year old Liana and her mother are
visiting the scene of the attack at the
Munich shopping mall
her friends were roughly the same age as
her they were killed in the mass
shooting that happened here in mid-july
she won't directly serve our haircut had
been on the way here myself but then my
sister's husband called and said we
shouldn't go I thought something was
happening as a revenge we were almost
there but we turned around and went home
I knew my friends might be there it's
where a lot of us hang out some good
after school around so I was pretty
scared I put the news on as soon as I
got home my friends and I started
communicating on what's happened
Facebook embassy Nancy pizza for trying
to work out who might either and who
definitely wasn't I love Ryan davion
suffered dish wats app on Facebook's and
then it turned out Lou two of our
friends have been killed beneath the
pelvis there was a terrible shock than a
t-shirt avez gosh did this to a friend
from mega storms and it is a total shock
images and videos were soon circulating
on the internet an 18 year old had gone
on a shooting spree he killed nine
people injured many more and then shot
himself he appears to have deliberately
targeted young people with a migrant
background like himself and like iana
how have you been since then can you
sleep garnished no I can't be fine I cry
all the time said it's just our phone
shaky it's a horrible feeling to know
that the person you used to hang out
with chat with is gone just like that I
fossil this is it feels awful lately
strictly his curfew
yanas friend Sal chuck was 15 years old
he liked football and Thai boxing all
she has left of him are photos on her
mobile phone
she ups love girly fresh bunking in a
way it still hasn't sunk in as he said I
often think he's still alive but he
isn't he's gone malabar this house mr.
this is the second time that Jana and
her mother are visiting the scene of the
shootings an anchor Kington locals
discuss how firsthand the attack was
they knew the gunman he was bullied in
school but seemed from the outside like
a nice kid Barnett of English ok most
worthiness they feel lucky to be alive
so Kenny's TV
myself you much talking to others helps
Jana process the tragedy people here
still can't grasp what happened
it's hard for her to come to terms with
the fact that she's still alive when her
friends were murdered
this with how do you feel now when
you're out and about on your own do you
go out no I haven't dared go anywhere by
myself yet the gunman was a German with
Iranian parents he wasn't a radical
Islamist but had far-right sympathies he
lived here in the Munich suburb of mucks
washed out Philippe under zone is a
migration expert based in Munich even
though the motives behind the recent
wave of attacks in Germany varied could
the perpetrators migrant backgrounds be
a factor the oskins also found the only
found like outsiders when people are
waiting for asylum applications to be
processed they live in a permanent state
of uncertainty leaves the other
permanent OMG guide as of us all from
holiday don't know if they'll be able to
stay d blatant good not elite and on top
of the embassy they've been forced to
flee a country and have some traumatic
experiences behind them that obviously
makes it harder for them to settle and
find peace but is in here to work on a
fishery other the gunman was born in
Munich Security in the city remains
tight against the backdrop of the recent
incidents many fear arise in copycat
crimes
as when zaardon con is this a few life
in in general whenever a very dramatic
incident occurs it gives rise to an
atmosphere that might encourage others
who harbors similar inclinations a multi
food disk ensign it's possible that a
climate develops that's conducive to
copycat crimes as for hotter than ear
than these Disney Swift and eat is that
what happened just two days after the
mass shootings in Munich a young man
died after setting off an explosive
outside a music festival in Ansbach 200
kilometers away
thomas meister is the pastor at the
nearby st. ghum Berta's church he was
there when the bomb went off and helped
look after people who witnessed what had
happened give on here Hamlin we were
here enjoying the concert from a
distance in the water upstairs in my
apartment when we heard the explosion in
the north when I came out to see what
was going on five minutes later we saw
the paramedics leading people outside
not only as congestive good food fan
antonio paten awesome de la vida her
dolls once them so I suggested they come
into our courtyard to be looked after
and for thought we had mckernon thomas
meister help take care of them 15 were
injured and many more were in shock the
attacker himself died when the device he
was carrying exploded in the middle of
on Spock's old town to locals it felt
like terrorism had reached their
doorstep when it transpired that the man
was a Syrian asylum seeker who would
apparently had ties to is
lockton right signal recent information
indicates this was the first suicide
attack perpetrated in the name of is in
germany deutschland how does it feel
something like this happening in your
town associate move you don't fund from
mentioned you thong a lot of people have
been asking why here but I've been here
why here in this idyllic town the climb
stats fearon they think this sort of
thing happens elsewhere in the big
cities bethere not on the doorstep of
about it here it's foolish via and it's
a very frightening feeling it's hard to
have something like this happen so close
to home but I needed but I think we all
know that it can ultimately happen
anywhere there's a self-employed pasion
Connie Reverend Meister is saddened to
see people such as the ants bak attacker
using religion to justify violence
he says his own faith helps him comfort
others through this difficult time yet i
deceived was that if you want to help
people you need to have empathy but you
have to be able to understand how people
feel things he can do this but you can't
be part of their suffering so these neta
are all I need to keep a distance as do
doctors and nurses when they help people
like you can say if we were done and you
can only help others if you don't dwell
on your own feelings yeah but put them
aside Kern's your face I'm to heaven
back in Munich migration expert Philip
Andersson is visiting the scene of the
recent mass shooting
he says the attack has changed the city
unequivocally henan natale cobraman d
it's very sad to see all the cuddly toys
and personal messages nollie discipline
it really brings home how people can be
hit by brutal tragedy from one minute to
the next and that we're not really able
to process it emotionally once again the
recent attacks have left anger grief and
fear in their wake Germany has taken
them very personally Anderson says it's
too soon to know what the long-term
repercussions will be in VA understandin
Josie and German angst gaben Vidic it
remains to be seen how much fear will
remain it depends what happens next if
there are more attacks then fear will
take root but if they aren't I think the
mood will pass this is evidently it's
understandable that a lot of people are
feeling nervous right now but they're
scared of what might happen in the
public arena moose meat sign it's
understandable but it's not inevitable
and I do believe that our society has a
basic stability that we can depend on I
don't think that fear will take hold and
become part of our lives why did one
does it was extended for those whose
lives were immediately impacted by the
recent attacks fear might take longer to
subside
Germany has learned the hard way that it
too is vulnerable
you